Hello, everybody.
Hello, hello.
Okay, guys.
If I do sound low energy, it's because a lot of stuff has been going on.
I didn't get to have my nap time in the end.
I'm very sad.
I had no nap time.
I had, like, work stuff to do.
And I am still sick, as you can tell.
I am... I do sound sick because...
I am still sick.
I took some meds just then.
And I'm getting better.
My nose is not as stuffy anymore.
It's just my throat right now.
You know, it doesn't sound like a dying whale.
But, like, that's usually what happens when I get sick.
I get hit the hardest in my throat.
So, I am starting to cough again.
Which sucks.
Because I hope I don't cough for a month plus.
This won't be a super long stream today.
Since I do have Tokyo Alley in Australia to do.
I have a convention in Australia for Tokyo Alley.
And Perth.
Which would be a meet and greet.
And a panel later tonight.
So, obviously, uh... I can't stay for too long.
So, I can still have a voice for it.
The other two things.
Just so you guys know.
I scheduled all of this before I got sick.
And now that I got sick.
I now have to be aware of all these other things.
I don't know how.
This always happens.
I would, like, schedule some things.
And then I would be like, everything will be fine.
Obviously, everything was not fine.
Because other stuff started happening.
So, this always happens.
I'd be like, I can't wait.
I'm looking forward to this week.
And then something happens.
And I was like, oh...
Guess... Guess this week is gonna be hard.
Another thing is that...
Okay.
So, I won't be doing these Doki Amber Doge updates.
On...
On Twitter.
Uh, for a while.
Because, like, it's all sort of up in the air.
I don't wanna make you guys feel too sad.
I don't wanna make you guys feel down.
It's also why I'm, like, really tired and exhausted.
Obviously, there's a lot of stuff going on at the moment.
So, like, I'm not taking care of myself very well.
Because of it.
And I do live alone.
Um, so...
Uh, regarding, like...
I got an abrupt date today.
And a lot of you guys are curious about it.
And, like, want to know how he's doing.
And everything.
Um...
I'm trying not to sound sad.
But I am exhausted.
Um...
And I'm gonna use this stream to help, you know...
Help me keep my mind off things and everything.
And I hope it helps keep your mind off things.
And everything.
But I will be visiting him tonight.
At the hospital.
Um, after this stream.
Uh, just to see him.
And, you know, uh...
I heard that visiting hours end at 9.
So, I'm gonna be visiting him tonight.
After this stream.
And, uh...
Uh, because he is gonna be staying another night.
At the hospital.
Um, we could've discharged him today.
But I decided to...
I know it's gonna, you know, obviously cost more money.
I'm gonna get pet insurance after this.
Because he might need long-term, uh...
Medication in the future.
Which is why, like, I'm a little down because of it.
Uh, so I will be getting pet insurance after this.
And, uh...
After, like, the entire...
After the entire incident of this is over.
I will be getting pet insurance.
Uh, because there is a possibility that I will have to get prescribed medication for him.
Long-term wise.
Um, but basically...
Um, it was my choice to keep him there an extra night.
Because of the new medication he's gonna be on.
Starting today.
Um, and I got really worried.
Because they're telling me...
Some of the things that might happen.
And I got really fucking worried.
I won't tell you guys.
But...
I was like...
I'll rather prefer he stays in the hospital...
For one more night.
Because I wanna be sure...
That nothing new comes up.
Because of it.
Um...
So...
Uh...
So they're like...
Yeah, that's understandable.
Because he could have been discharged today.
But I was so scared...
That, like, something was gonna happen.
So now I was like...
It's safer.
And easier to have him there instead.
Um...
So basically...
The old medications...
Might have given him some side effects...
That was really harsh on his kidneys.
And because of that...
He's being taken off...
On his old medication.
And being given...
Two new medications...
That he's taking right today...
Starting today.
Um...
That will be...
Or starting yesterday.
I think it was started yesterday.
That night.
That would be easier on him.
Um...
He's stable.
He's eating.
He's drinking.
Um...
He is not...
Uh...
He's not...
He did vomit last night.
But only a little bit.
And he had a little...
Oh wait...
Yeah, he had a little diarrhea.
So like...
He is getting better.
So what...
Yesterday I was talking about...
During yesterday's stream...
Um...
Was that...
He's peeing out his protein.
And we don't know why.
And we think it's a side effect...
From the medication...
He was taking...
For his surgery.
Because it was really hard...
That specific medication...
Is very harsh...
On the kidneys.
And because of that...
It might have triggered something...
That may...
Is making him...
Pee out his protein.
So...
His...
We're giving him...
A new medication...
That's gonna help...
Fix his protein levels.
Because...
Um...
It's not really good...
That he's peeing out...
Like his protein.
Um...
So like...
His protein is like...
Really low right now.
So we're giving him medication...
To help with that.
And...
Uh...
Um...
And so...
Uh...
So this medication should help.
But...
In a couple of weeks...
I have to come back...
And check up on him...
Like for internal...
To see if the medication is helping.
And if...
Internally...
If he's okay.
Because like...
There's...
Like...
Kidney-wise...
We don't know...
What exactly is going on.
Um...
And...
I do have...
So like...
We're just...
Trying to figure that out.
But...
Uh...
But we did look at the urine samples...
And that's basically what we meant by like...
Yeah...
His...
There's like...
He's...
His pee is weird.
Like...
Um...
So...
Uh...
We're picking him up tomorrow.
The dog sitter is picking him up...
Me and the dog sitter are picking him up tomorrow.
Um...
With his new sense of medication.
We're gonna be supervising him...
To make sure he doesn't have any...
Uh...
Side effects.
And like...
Effects from...
Like...
If he has like...
Too low protein...
There are...
Effects...
That would...
Show up...
On his body.
And stuff like that.
And his behavior.
So...
Tomorrow is when like...
It's like hard supervision.
And I'm really happy that...
Um...
The dog sitter...
It will...
Is aware...
Is aware of it.
And will be supervising him for me.
And help making sure that...
You know...
Everything will be okay.
And...
Um...
You know...
The dog sitter got really worried.
They're like...
We can pick him up earlier.
So he doesn't have to stay in the hospital...
Like the whole day.
And everything.
And I really...
Appreciate that.
Because like...
Obviously like...
They really love dad as well.
And like...
And were like...
Really concerned.
Was asking me updates every day.
Uh...
Via text.
And they said they could even pick him up earlier.
If needed be.
Uh...
To like...
You know...
Make sure he's more like...
Being with like...
You know...
Family and stuff.
And being with people he knows.
Instead of being stuck in the hospital.
But...
I did make the decision to...
Put him in there for an extra day.
Um...
Just because...
Uh...
Just because I got really...
Worried and scared.
Because like...
You know...
Whenever you hear stuff from the...
What the vet was telling me.
I got really scared.
And I was just like...
God...
You guys can keep it for an extra day.
Like...
I...
I don't want...
I don't know if like...
Something's gonna happen.
Yeah.
Um...
So especially if he's on new medication.
And things like...
Um...
And like...
Uh...
Yeah.
And then you know how like...
The doctor...
When the vet's talking to you.
And they're like...
It could be this.
It could be that.
It could be this disease.
And I was like...
I was like...
What?
Like...
I was just like...
He came here for a...
Broken spine.
And now he has a million things going on?
I was like...
What's wrong with you?
Like...
I was like...
I thought it was just the spine.
How did all of this came to be?
Like...
So...
Uh...
Yeah.
Peek wiener dog experience.
Mother...
I am a monster.
I was like...
Why did...
You had all...
So many underlying stuff...
That happened.
I...
I thought I just had to worry about...
The spine.
And then like...
Aftercare.
And...
Now...
I have like...
A million other things now I'm worrying about.
And the possibility of...
Well, there is...
He is going to be on long-term medication...
Regarding the kidney now.
So...
Uh...
So there's that.
Because I was like...
How are you peeing out protein?
They were like...
Has he ever had...
Like...
Did he ever like...
Peed a lot?
Or like...
Had issues with like...
Vomiting and diarrhea?
I was like...
No...
Then they're like...
Yeah...
So...
This could be the side effects from the earlier...
Meds...
That he took...
That could have triggered...
Um...
That...
This was an underlying thing that he had...
But the medication...
Finally...
Like...
It was a dormant thing...
That he had...
And then the...
The meds...
Could have had...
The side effect was...
It triggered this dormant thing that he had...
And now he started...
Peeing out his protein...
So I was like...
Excuse me?
He was like...
Dad!
What the fuck?
Um...
Yeah...
Because they're like...
Did he try...
Did he pee a lot?
And I was like...
No, he peed...
Normal amount...
Like...
I was like...
No!
He...
He had a normal experience...
Uh...
Yeah...
So...
Uh...
No, they didn't screw up his meds...
Because it's the usual medication...
That they give...
Because like...
This is like...
It was like a...
It's...
You know...
Like...
It's typical wiener dog...
Experience...
Uh...
So...
It's not like...
They screw up the meds...
Because every...
This is like...
A typical wiener dog...
Thing...
That...
Happens...
Uh...
For wiener dogs...
And like...
This is like...
The usual thing...
They either prescribe...
To...
Um...
To dogs...
Who have gone through...
Uh...
Like...
The spine surgery...
And...
Um...
Obviously like...
It...
The one...
The side facts was that...
It could be really harsh on the kidneys...
And that was what's going on for him right now...
Like his...
It like...
Like...
His kidneys was not adjusting very well...
With...
Uh...
With the new medication...
With the medication he was on...
So now he's on new sets of medication...
To help him with...
Uh...
Because like...
After he was on that medication...
He was having...
Diarrhea...
And he was vomiting...
So like...
Um...
Obviously after that we went back and then they're like, yeah, we're gonna give him these two new medications.
Because I asked him like, that's a lot of medication.
And they were like, okay, they're like, yes, but we are taking him off with the other two that he was on.
Because he was on four different types of medication after the surgery, which was typical to prescribe after back surgery.
Um, and usually the surgery is, um, usually the surgery is for, for wiener dogs, for dachshunds.
Uh, like most of the surgery, like, cause like, majority of surgery this happens to is for dachshunds.
Because they like to fucking jump and they're not supposed to jump.
And that's why they break their backs.
Um, well they didn't break their back, it's like a disc, like a disc thing.
I don't remember the full name, but it's like a disc thing.
And that's like the normal surgery for wiener dogs.
And, um, and, uh, so he was on four different types of medication.
So we're taking him off on two of them.
Yeah, the disc clip.
Yeah.
So he had a slipped disc and we had to like cut the disc and stuff like that.
And so, um, we're putting him on, we're, we took off two of the medication that he was on.
And, uh, putting him on two new ones to like replace the ones that were as harsh on his kidneys.
And, uh, so that's like the current update on him.
And I do have ramps.
I bought a new set of ramps.
The thing is, um, he, I did have ramps, but he likes to jump down.
Uh, he likes to jump down from my bed and he refused to use the ramps.
And now that, so then like, um, so I'm gonna, I bought like a new set of ramps that will be in the front.
Cause I had one ramp that was just for my bed for him to go up.
And then he like, he like gets impatient.
He jumps down.
So I bought another set of ramps for him to get down from the front of my bed.
Cause he, cause I put the stairs, the ramp stairs at the back of my bed, at the side of my bed, at the back.
Um, so he gets lazy and now, so then if I put two on there, one in the front, and then he sees the front ramps, then he'll go down on the ramps from the front.
So that's like how I'm gonna see it, but obviously he needs to recover.
He's walking, but he's, okay, so like, this is the most fucked up thing for me.
Cause like, he's getting better with walking.
Like he's improving on his walking, but now it's his kidneys.
So I'm like, you can, like, he's actually, he's getting better.
Like he would wobble a little bit after his surgery, but now he's like walking normally again.
But now it's his kidneys.
So I'm like, what's wrong with you?
Yeah.
Um, um, um, yeah.
I mean, the surgery was for walking.
So, um, um, or um, yeah.
So he's just a little box.
He's like, surprise!
Surprise!
There's another thing!
Uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh.
Yeah, his mutant genes have activated.
Uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, yeah.
So, um, he had, he wasn't able to walk before.
But obviously he was like... he was like stumbling because obviously he just had back surgery.
So he was like stumbling and stuff like that wobbly.
But now it's better now.
And then... but then obviously the newest thing is now to figure out his kidney issue.
So I don't know but I still... they did tell me on Monday... like yesterday they told me on Monday we're getting... we might have to do an ultra scan to make sure there's nothing...
else related.
Nothing else other than related to it.
So I'm not sure yet if Monday is still a thing.
Because they did tell me... because today is a different vet.
Because the other vet that usually takes care of his dad.
Doesn't show up on the weekends.
So this vet was like telling me how like...
Yeah, our newest plan is blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And then I was like, okay, so he's going to be on meds for a couple of weeks, and then for the kidney, and then we're going to check back into the hospital to see if it has any improvement or anything.
So, yep, all right.
But that is the current update with Dad.
So, I hope everything will be okay by tomorrow.
And then tomorrow, he'll be heading back home.
Well, not home.
He'll be heading to the dog sitter for them to supervise him.
I wish he could come home, but obviously with my schedule, I'm really worried.
I cannot supervise him 24-7.
I would wish I could, but obviously I live alone, and I do have a lot of work obligations and everything.
So, obviously, I cannot look after him 24-7 to make sure he doesn't have any negative side effects or symptoms that might show up with the current issues that he's having.
So, yeah.
I really appreciate everybody for all the support for him.
And, like, we've had good news that he's stable, that he's eating, that he's drinking, and everything.
That everybody's like, yeah, he has, like, he's perked up.
He has energy and everything.
So, like, that makes me really happy.
I'm gonna ask the hospital, like, what kind of food to recommend him during his hospital stay.
So, maybe, like, maybe, like, we'll just feed him whatever he was being fed at the hospital.
Because I felt like whatever he's been eating at the hospital has been going okay for him.
So, like, I'll just go with that.
Yeah, so there's more positive news than negative news.
Obviously, I am.
There's, like, an underlying fear for me.
But, like, as a concerned pet owner, you know, that's, like, that's something that, you know, the thought that's, like, for everybody.
But thank you, everybody, for support.
Thank you all for the super chat.
It has been very expensive.
So, I really do appreciate all the support going throughout all of it.
And, obviously, I'm not taking care of myself, too.
I have been absolutely not taking care of myself throughout all of this.
So, yeah, because, like, my manager was, like, yeah, like, I understand.
And, like, you gotta eat healthier and, like, you know, I'm not...
I gotta go outside a bit more, too.
Like, after I recover from me sick, obviously.
And, obviously, I can't really go outside.
Like, usually, Dad helps me with going outside more.
And, obviously, since he's been, you know, going in and out of the hospital and being at the dog sitter, I haven't been going out as much anymore, if any.
Because I don't have to walk him and touch grass.
So, that was sort of, like, an issue, obviously.
So, like, it's just taking things one at a time.
Like, my first priority is making sure Dad is okay.
And that there's no other, like, you know, there's nothing else to worry about after that.
But, again, like I said, I really appreciate everybody for the support and for the well wishes and for being here.
It really helps.
Talking about this helps a lot for me, too.
I hope it doesn't make you guys too sad.
Like, there's more positive news than there is sad news.
And, like, he is stable.
He is stable.
He is...
Health-wise, it seems like he's okay.
It's just that we are looking, making sure that he will be okay after the hospital.
Like, after the discharge.
And there's no, like, you know, there's no other...
Nothing else happening afterwards.
And it's just going to, you know, just going back to the checkup and just making sure he's okay and everything.
But I hope it doesn't make you guys too sad or anything.
But, like, update-wise, he is doing okay.
He is stable.
I'll be visiting him.
I'll be visiting him today after this stream.
This might not be a very long stream either.
So, just because I do have two other things to do tonight.
We're writing my panel in Australia and my meet and greets.
But thank you guys for so much support.
I bet Dad misses you guys too.
And I know Dad misses us a lot.
And I miss him too.
And I know you guys miss him as well.
I know you guys miss hearing him fucking demanding me for food.
That's for sure.
Zekra, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Parents for Dad, please take care of both of you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Johnny Lacombe, thank you for the super chat.
Chat stream, welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Yes, you guys miss him being his goddamn fucking bratty self.
Another life update.
Tomorrow, I'll be streaming the early access of Apex Legends.
If you guys didn't know, I already tweeted about that.
I tweeted about it today, actually.
Just then.
But, yes, I will be doing the early access, I believe.
Okay, here's the image.
I'll just push the image out.
Okay, there you go.
So, I have the early access for the newest season.
Which is the release of their newest hero and all the other changes.
I did play Apex yesterday.
Just because I was, like, curious.
Like, you know, just because last time I touched Apex was March.
So, I played Apex yesterday to, like, you know, brush up on everything.
And, like, you know, just to, like, remember how to play the game.
And now I realize why everybody was complaining about the P20.
Like, yeah, like, I mean, I'm still good with the bow check.
But now I know why everyone was hard complaining about the P20.
The dual P20s.
And, yeah.
Like, no, like, that...
Yeah, it's fun to play use.
It's...
It's fun to use.
But, like...
It's not fun to die to it either.
And everybody is there.
It's always just P20s.
It's P20s everywhere.
Um...
Yeah.
Uh...
It's not fun to die to it.
But it is very fun.
I don't know which character is meta.
But it doesn't matter.
I'll be playing a new character anyway when I can.
I was trying out with different characters.
Just to figure out, like, what is fun to play on at the moment.
For, like...
Like, solos and stuff.
For tomorrow.
So, um...
When...
Um...
I'm not sure.
I'm not sure yet.
Um...
What...
If I can't get the new...
What's his name?
I don't even know.
Alter...
I...
Okay.
I think Alter...
Is...
I tried using Alter...
And I was doing, like...
Team plays and stuff.
That was good for my team.
But, like...
I...
She's so...
I don't like playing her...
To frag.
It's so hard to, like...
I feel like...
It's difficult to frag with her.
Because she's such a...
She's just a character for...
As...
For your team.
Not for yourself.
And...
Because I...
I...
I tried her out.
And I did more damage...
On every other character...
But Alter...
Like...
I did, like...
I...
I had her for one game...
And then, like...
I did 500 damage...
But we won the game...
Because I had, like...
Like...
Game-changing alts...
That, like...
Helped my team...
And I played every other character...
And then all the other characters...
I had, like...
2k plus damage...
And I was like...
Yeah, like...
So, like, I was like, this is not fun.
Like, 2k plus, I was playing, yeah, I was doing rank.
I was playing bronze rank.
And then, like, all the other characters, because I played, like, I think I played, like, four to five games.
And then all the other characters, yeah, helping the team?
Boring.
Like, screw helping my fucking team.
And then every other character I played, I had 2k plus damage.
So, it was like, I was like, I just felt like, I know I did one game for Altered, but I was just like, it just did not feel like, um, it wants to support my teammates.
Exactly.
I'm here to frag.
I'll use someone else's Altered.
Yeah, but Apex is not about being a healer.
Apex is, like, more fun.
Apex is more fun when you can shoot your gun.
Like, it's different from Marvel Rivals.
Um, and I'm more used to, like, I'm more used to... Okay, it was one character, Gus.
Oh, ignore the other characters I got 2k plus damage on.
Like, like...
I'm here to explain why I didn't like Altered.
I even... I... Okay, and then we had... Okay, actually, we had a Smurf.
Um, I had a Smurf with me.
And then, like...
And, cause, like, they were, like, a level 27, gold 2.
Well, I was, you know, Bronze 2 or something, cause I ranked up to Bronze 2 at that point.
Like, it took me, like, 4... 4 games to... Almost...
It took me, like, 3 games to get a Bronze 2 from the lower Bronze.
And then, like, we had a level... Cause, like, level 20 is, like, um...
You can play rank, right?
So, level 27... Sorry, I know we haven't done the Simpsons thing yet.
Look, this is my... This usually... This part is gonna be after the stream would be done.
But I'm doing it in the beginning, because, like...
Usually, I just go bye now after... After the stream is done.
Cause I used up all my voices.
It's the only time I can talk to you guys before I lose my voice.
Like, not crashing out in the Simpsons.
Um...
But, like...
We had a Smurf that was a level 27.
Um...
And, uh...
And...
And she was on Alter.
And then, I was on Conduit.
I was on Conduit.
Cause I was playing different characters every game.
Just to get a feel.
Cause, like, you know, it's been a while since I played, uh...
Apex.
So, I was experimenting with every character.
I was experimenting with characters every game.
Just to be, like...
Just to get a feel of Apex again.
Cause it's been a while since I played Apex.
So, that game with the Smurf...
Uh, who was on Altair, uh, Gull 2, level 27, so I knew, like, this guy was not, like, on his main account, because a lot of, like, you know, obviously, like, looking at the rank and the levels, and, and I was on Kanyo, because I wanted to figure out, like,
just try to get a feel playing different characters, and seeing what is, what I feel good on, like, at that moment.
And even that guy, I thought he was doing really well, because he was doing, like, really sick plays on Altair, like, the portals, and, like, the alts, and everything.
And all that shit, and then I looked at, we won the game, like, like, we won, and I looked at the damage score line, the stat line, and I think I had, like, 1.8k damage, and then I was, like, yeah, okay, that makes sense.
And then, like, and then our altar had 600.
I was, like, what the fuck?
I was, like, wait, you did nothing?
I thought he did a lot.
I was, like, oh, man, my altar's pretty good.
Like, these are some really good alts, and some really good, like, like, portal placement, like, good util.
This util was really good.
I think my altar is doing so well.
Oh, man, look, oh, he killed some guy.
And then, like, I was, like, 1.9k.
All right, 1.9k.
I was in top fragger.
Our third got 2.3k or some shit, or, and then, and then Altair was, like, 600k.
And I was, like, wait a minute.
I was just, like, wait a minute.
What?
Oh, man, I thought that guy was a really good player, though.
But, um, but, yeah.
But, yeah, I just feel like Altair is definitely a, like, they know what they were doing.
Like, they know what they were clearly doing.
It was just, like, um, I just think Altair was just not a frag character.
It's literally support and, um, it's support and, like, um, and util.
And I don't know.
Maybe, maybe I'm wrong.
But from the games I was playing, that's how I felt when I played her.
And how I saw from the other guy that was playing her.
Because I thought I was doing well with util.
I just can't, I just can't frag with her for some fucking reason.
Um, uh, but, 600 damage, Altair, let's go!
That's like, you go, you go, Altair!
Um, uh, but, yeah, so, I was experimenting a little bit.
But on Sunday, I will be doing a, um, I will, on Sunday, I'll be doing my, uh, 9am, I'll be on at 9am tomorrow.
Um, for, because that's when the whole early access drops, so you guys can see the new character.
And on Twitch, I'll be doing a...
So, I will have a sponsor stream on Monday.
But, um, it's not fully confirmed yet.
Um, I haven't signed anything for it yet.
So, I'm still waiting on the details on that.
So, I can't confirm anything.
But, I am required to stream an out...
Like, this will be on Twitch on Monday.
So, on Monday, um, this will be on Monday.
Um, and, um, I am required to stream something...
And it'll be on Twitch, by the way.
The Monday stream will be on Twitch.
The Sunday stream is gonna be on YouTube.
On Monday, for the sponsor, I have to be live an hour before the sponsor stream.
So, I'll be using that hour to play Apex Legends.
Because I'm allowed to.
Um, because I'm allowed to do whatever I want.
An hour before the sponsor stream.
And, you only have to watch 30 minutes to get your Twitch drops.
So, most likely on Twitch on Monday, it'll be at 4pm.
So, it's not gonna be as degenerate as the 9am one for Monday.
Or, for Sunday.
Sunday will be 9am.
Monday will be at 4pm.
And you just need to watch 30 minutes to get your Twitch drops, I believe.
Um, so, uh, so I will stream an hour of the Apex stuff before I go to the sponsor on Twitch.
Um, and, look.
For me, like, 9am is not an okay time for me to wake up.
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
So, I, for me, that's not okay for me.
Um, anyway, so, that is the whole life update situation.
Um, but on Twitch, uh, on Twitch, it will be 4pm, uh, for an hour of Apex for the Twitch drops.
And then we're gonna go straight to sponsor, which has not been confirmed yet.
So, that's why I can't give too much details on what it is.
But if it doesn't go through, um, actually, let me see.
Let me double check, because I know, like, I'll see if I have to sign anything yet.
No.
Okay.
So, um, nothing has been fully confirmed yet.
Um, because I haven't signed anything yet.
So, I'm just waiting on that.
And then when I...
when it's fully confirmed, then I'll, like, talk about it fully.
Uh...
Um, because I can't say anything about the sponsor until I sign something.
Anyway.
We can finally play Simpsons.
Alright.
Life update over.
That was a long...
I'm sorry.
That was a really long life update.
But now...
Now it's the gameplay time.
Um...
There was a lot of stuff.
Okay.
There was a lot of stuff to update you guys on.
To be fair.
Okay.
I should double check the sound, too.
I forgot.
Okay.
What was my Simpsons?
Simpsons...
Okay.
20.6.
So, yeah.
I always write down what I have...
what...
what I have to put it on for long.
Also, for the people who are like, hee hee, she has to redo everything.
When my game crashed last night, or last time, I play this game, I replayed every...
You know, I replayed everything for us.
So, we don't have to replay the...
all the progress I've lost.
So, how much progress did I lose?
Well, um...
It was basically where...
It was basically...
Look, see?
It's like nothing bad has happened.
Like...
I made sure...
It was on the same day I had crashed out.
Okay?
It was the same day I crashed out.
Okay, guys?
And, um...
I...
I made sure...
We...
We got back to where we were before I crashed out.
I...
Fuck.
Okay, I can't remember the controls.
Um...
Let me remember the controls before we do anything.
Okay, which car...
We'll do...
Fuck.
Okay.
We'll do Mr. Plow.
Mr. Plow for this.
I think Mr. Plow would be good.
Alright.
And we were...
So, basically...
Guys, I need to figure out the controls before...
Okay.
Okay, I need to figure out the controls.
Alright.
So, basically, when I crashed out and my game also crashed, I...
They put me back all the way to...
Before...
Oh my god, what was it?
They put me all the way to...
Heading to the retirement home.
So, I had to do all of that again.
So...
Remember when I had to go drive to the school and get the...
And get the stupid colas?
Or whatever.
The buzz cola?
Yeah, I had to do all of that again.
So, I did all of that again on the day the game crashed out on me.
Alright.
It's okay.
But everything is fine now.
Uh...
Yes, the game crashed.
Star Ace.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It is understandable to crash out on the Simpsons hit and run.
If you didn't crash out on the Simpsons hit and run, you are a sociopath.
You should get tested.
That's what I'll say.
If you've never crashed out playing this game, you should get tested.
I...
Oh my god.
There's...
There is no reason for you to not crash out.
I...
I will say that.
Alright.
Let's see.
I can do this.
Alright.
Nice.
Please.
For real.
Especially if you were a child.
There's no way a child is most more emotionally mature than what you are now.
I refuse to believe you were more emotionally mature than you were now as an adult.
There is...
Especially if you were a child going through purity, you have no fucking control of your emotions.
That was me!
Okay.
It's okay, guys.
I'm doing it.
I'm figuring it out.
I'm hitting the car.
Okay.
Nice.
I didn't crash out, but I was a child.
Loved the game a lot, even the last mission.
What?
Oh, no, no.
Not the not the popo.
Okay, I need to make sure I don't get the popo on me.
Okay.
We have to go now.
Okay, I'm gonna I'm gonna let this cool down a little bit before I do anything.
All right.
Well, Martrico, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You were a very emotionally mentally mature child for you to not crash out on this fucking game.
I'm gonna wait until like I'm gonna wait until I don't have the police wanting to you know arrest me.
Give me the sec.
All right.
Joke's on you.
I was already tested before playing this game.
I turned out positive for autism.
L, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
At least at least you were a very mature child.
At least you learned.
All right.
We gotta wait, guys.
We're waiting because we don't want the police on me.
All right.
I don't want the police on me right now, so I gotta wait.
We can play the waiting game, guys.
We can play the waiting game.
I'm not going through all of that again.
We can do it.
Gotta play the waiting game.
All right, nice.
All right, where is... whoops.
I say as I start causing more havoc.
It's causing more mayhem as I fucking do this.
You can't go anywhere now.
I blocked the only way to come in.
That's right.
What you gonna do?
I blocked the only entrance.
That's right.
What you gonna do?
Nothing.
Oh, you're gonna do that?
Okay, wait.
Wait a minute.
That doesn't follow my plan.
What you gonna do?
Nothing.
Oh, wait.
You just drove around me.
Okay.
I should have expected that.
Who would have thought that's what he's gonna do?
Oh, yeah?
I blocked this hole.
What you gonna do now?
Nothing.
I blocked the hole.
That's right.
Stop hitting yourself.
I blocked the hole.
Oh!
That's right.
Now you definitely can't do anything.
Keep hitting yourself.
That's right.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
It's fine.
I can wait.
That's fine.
I can still wait.
I blocked the only hole.
Okay.
This is fucking my camera.
Maybe I should like...
I don't know what's going on.
Okay.
Nice.
He just has to hit himself one time.
Oh, no.
I feel like I fucked up.
I played around.
I played with the food for too long, guys.
Oh, no.
Guys.
Nice.
It doesn't matter.
Okay.
We wait.
We...
It's okay.
I see him.
He's right over there.
Not even close.
I see him.
He's right over there.
I can wait.
All right.
We're ready.
Okay.
Mr. Fucking truck.
He waited.
Okay.
That truck waited for me.
I'm... Okay.
That was actually bullshit.
Oh, my God.
This is a conspiracy right there.
Okay.
I need to find a wrench.
I'm not okay right now.
My car is not okay, guys.
I actually need a wrench right now.
Oh, no.
Are there any nearby wrenches?
Guys, I don't think I can...
Oh, no.
I need a wrench.
Oh, there's a wrench right here.
Thank God.
Okay.
I can continue.
Fuck.
It's okay.
I can cut him out right here.
All right.
Where is he?
There we go.
It's fine.
That's fine.
Oh, no.
That's not fine.
Oh.
No.
I hit myself.
Okay.
I hate this.
It's always the last truck.
It's always the last bus cola.
It's always the last one.
Oh, my God.
Hey, look at that turn, though.
Okay.
That turn was fucking sick, though.
Not gonna lie.
That was a sick-ass turn.
Please.
Hit that.
Yes!
Oh, my God.
No!
Oh, ho, ho!
Oh,
my God.
Please.
Oh, my God.
There's no way.
And I'm fine.
And I get busted.
I can't.
I fucking...
I hate this car.
Okay.
I can do this.
It's fine.
I'm learning.
I got better.
I improved.
The goddamn...
Po, po!
It looks so promising, too.
It looks so promising.
I finished the first car so fast.
I made him hit himself.
I played with my food for too long.
Hit yourself.
Hit yourself now.
You got it.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, I just had that...
Keep crashing that tree.
Nice.
Sorry about that.
There we go.
He's confused.
That's good.
Be confused.
All right.
Whoops.
Ow.
My tushy.
Yes, crash.
Keep crashing.
I hope they're all right.
Okay.
This is not fair.
The police should exempt me from any arrest for what I'm doing.
I am a law-abiding citizen trying to make sure the children stay safe.
I am here for the children.
Won't anyone think about the children?
I don't understand.
How am I a criminal when I'm doing this for the kids?
Where is it?
Okay.
Oh.
I...
What?
Okay, guys.
Give me a sec.
I have to deal with a hit and run right now.
That's fine.
Oh my god it's fine.
Oh my god thank god he like pushed me back.
Can't catch me now cops.
Okay wait he's right there.
Wait the cops right behind me isn't he?
It's fine.
It's okay.
I'm almost free.
Come on it's so close.
The cops can't catch me.
No!
Oh my god.
Oh my god I'm nearly like one step behind the cops.
No don't touch me.
Don't touch me.
Don't touch me!
Please!
Okay everything's okay.
Yay!
It's alright.
I'm with the kids now.
Oh it's fine.
Save the person running over kids.
Young thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright next car.
Save.
Okay next car time.
The third one is the most frustrating I would have to say.
The third one is so fucking frustrating.
Yeah see he doesn't regret anything.
I'm a law abiding citizen.
Move out of the way.
I'm also a cop.
Alright.
What you gonna do?
I blocked the hole.
That's fucking right.
I should have looked up speedrun strats for this.
I should have.
Like I should be legally allowed to look up speedrun strats for this game.
I hate this game.
Just for this part.
Just.
Just for this part guys.
Like anybody would have agreed.
With me.
That this has to be one of the more frustrating levels.
The ramming ones are definitely the more frustrating ones.
Alright.
Like how do they do this?
How do you speedrun this?
Just hit yourself.
Keep hitting yourself.
Yes.
Keep doing that.
No.
Why did you stop?
How did you get through the gold?
I don't understand.
Okay.
Nice.
There we go.
Okay.
I figured that part out.
Guys.
I'm figuring out the speedrun strats.
I'm figuring it out.
I'm making my own speedrun tech right now.
This is it.
I'm trademarking the tech.
My tech.
My tech right here.
Okay.
I call it.
The.
When there's a hole.
There's a goal.
Block the hole.
Okay.
This one is so hard because there's no actual area.
area to like lock the hole.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh my god.
This one is so difficult.
Like there's like no area for you to actually ram.
Oh wait.
I did it though.
I rammed it.
Okay.
Halfway.
I'm always like just short from killing this car.
Like just almost there.
Come on.
Oh my god.
I flipped it.
Flip.
Flipping it should be bonus points.
You know like.
Like Tony Hawk.
Like radical.
That should be a style point right there.
It does like extra damage every time you flip the truck.
move it or lose it buster.
That should be a style point.
Just like Tony Hawk.
Oh my god.
I don't understand.
I'm ramming it as much as I can.
Oh it rammed itself.
Oh thank god.
Okay.
Guys.
I figured it out.
Okay.
Alright.
Guys.
I figured it out.
My speedrun tech.
I trademarked it.
Don't worry.
I know what comes up after this, guys.
But don't worry.
I have the strat.
Guys, don't worry, guys.
Guys, don't worry.
I have the strat.
Don't worry.
Guys, I... This is to prove, you guys, that I read my YouTube comments.
Someone was like, after that stream, someone commented, was like, it's really funny that Dookie crashed out on that chase because all she had to do was go into the house and then she would have completed the mission.
And that is the proof to you guys that I do read my YouTube comments.
You did just for this one.
I wish I knew that years ago.
Why am I a poo now?
What?
It just... No cutscene?
I'm just a poo?
How did I get here?
How did...
Dookie can read.
There you go.
How did... How did I become a poo?
I'm just him now?
Krono, thank you for the 50 gifted chips.
Thank you.
I told you guys.
I told you I had the strat.
I came in prepared for hit and run.
I'm bombed him.
Alright, whoops.
Sorry, Gil.
Please ignore the things I posted in the YouTube comments.
Nexy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait, I wanna buy... Wait, is the police car good?
Is that a good investment?
Guys...
Being the police...
Am I exempt from the crap... from the law?
Oh my god, get over here!
You fucker!
It's decent, or is it bad?
Is Gil trying to scam me?
Cuz that's Gil thing.
That's a Gil thing to do.
It's not that good?
Okay.
Alright, I won't buy it.
Wait, she can't go get the...
Oh, I have to get the car made for Homer?
Wait, let me grab this bee first.
Actually, no, I feel...
I actually...
Oh my god, I'm gonna...
Goddamn...
Oh!
Get over here.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
Nice, okay.
It's fine.
I need to go grab a car.
I need to grab my own car.
Where is my car?
Wait, is that my car over there?
Oh!
Is that my car?
Whoops!
It's like...
Where is my car?
Hey, Apu!
I'll take six packs of bugs, cool, and at least expire hot dogs you have.
Soto!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Come again!
Whoops!
Sorry, lady!
Alright, this way.
Forgot he has a convertible, because he didn't think he had eight kids.
Where's the six kids?
I've lost count.
He has a lot of kids.
Alright.
Let's see.
And this was before Octuplets was a thing.
I wonder how she's doing.
Yup.
The Octuplets mom.
I wonder how she's doing over there.
Last thing I heard about her is that...
They divorced and then she did porn?
That was the last thing I heard about her.
And then she became irrelevant after that.
Because everything just...
Everybody was just like...
Talking about her because of like...
Oh yeah!
If you guys didn't know that.
Like, her and that other guy got divorced and then she did porn.
And then that's all I heard.
What, who?
The Octumom!
You know?
The...
There was a whole reality show about it and everything.
And...
No!
I'm talking about a real person!
Not Apu's wife!
Apu's wife isn't real!
I'm talking about the real woman that had eight children.
Yeah, Kate plus eight.
You know how...
It was not Kate plus eight?
It was like...
Kate and her husband.
I forgot his name.
But...
Like, he was obviously like the least relevant guy in that show.
Like, in...
In the family.
But like...
Um...
The show was John and...
I like how everybody says Kate plus eight.
But not John and Kate plus eight!
Everyone already forgot about John!
No!
There was!
There was a real person!
Behind!
There was a real...
Well...
Apu...
Apu was first.
Apu had the first...
Oh, I have to do something about this Buzzkoda.
I...
What if I kick it now?
Wait!
Oh my god!
What if...
I smash into the car?
I...
Accepted the mission accidentally.
Unless I redeem myself, I will be reincarnated as a sea cucumber.
Or worse...
Wait!
I must find the source of this evil beverage.
The soda invoice commanded I go here, but I see no cola factory.
Oh!
I just have to chase it?
Okay, okay.
I was gonna save.
I have to crash into it.
I'll pre-crash it.
I was gonna pre-crash it.
There was no bounds!
John did have a midlife crisis.
Cause he thought he was more important than the show.
But obviously, everybody felt... followed Cade over John.
I mean, everybody nearly went like, oh, you mean Cade plus A?
I was like, you guys do know it was...
There was a second guy in that show, right?
There was the father, too.
It was John and Cade plus A.
Okay.
Not just...
Not just Cade.
Okay.
Oh no, Apu.
Whoa!
Oh my god.
Bro, that looked so cool.
Okay.
Ooh, the Indian chase music goes hard on this.
It's...
I think my favorite Indian song is...
What is it?
Tuluk, tuluk, tuluk.
That was my favorite.
Cause I love the lore behind...
I love the lore behind the song.
The tunuk, tunuk.
That's one of my favorite Indian songs.
The lore behind that song is that...
Um...
Was that...
The reason why...
Before he did that music video...
Everyone was saying...
His criticism was that his music is only popular...
Because he has like beautiful women...
Um...
And background dancers in his song...
In his music videos.
And that's why his music is so popular.
So he...
Did the...
Tunuk, tunuk song...
To prove to everybody that...
His songs don't need beautiful backup dancers to be popular.
There.
Oh my god!
This is a conspiracy!
Are you fucking kidding me?
No way!
No fucking way did that car do that to me!
I...
He started a...
God damn car crash!
Yeah, he did.
Yeah, so he proved to everybody...
That like...
He didn't need beautiful women...
And that he can just make an extremely popular song...
Oh hey!
It's the pen pals!
With just...
Himself!
I mean, it worked!
Wait, what's in here?
The legitimate...
The legitimate business social club.
What's in here?
I wanna go in here!
Wait, I wanna...
I'm in!
I'm a legitimate business owner!
And he was...
Yeah, now it's his most popular song!
And now even people overseas know him!
But then he went...
Okay, look...
He can't...
He can't stop himself from being...
Look...
He can't stop himself from being beautiful, okay?
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Okay...
Jammo, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
I used to give my controller bite marks because of this game.
Yeah, I can see why.
I can see why.
This is a game to like...
Torture your little children.
Oh...
Okay, I have so much money to give to the cops soon.
Ha ha ha ha!
Look at all my...
Look at the amount of bail money that I have, guys!
Oh my god!
So much bail money!
Oh shit!
I'm just gonna fuck this up, aren't I?
No, no!
That was so close!
You almost shot me!
Look at all my bail money!
Woo!
Woooo!
Okay, nice.
Busted!
Minus 50!
Now I can get arrested by a cop seven more times!
I don't wanna...
I don't know.
I don't have Apu costumes here.
There's no costumes.
I think it's also the fact that Apu hasn't been...
They haven't used Apu for so long.
Which sucks.
I know like the reason why.
But like, you know...
He was still like a beloved character.
And...
Since he had his own character arcs and everything in the show.
But like...
I...
The fact that like Apu hasn't been around for so long.
There's like no costume that I really care to have from Apu.
Yeah, he has a really good backstory.
Yeah.
Oh wait!
A dress!
Okay, I take it back.
American Apu.
I take it all back.
American Apu was pretty good.
I...
American Apu.
From that episode.
That's right, I have a simulated into America now.
Oh shit.
Oh hey, it's...
What is it called?
I forgot what the mo...
The mow drink that is.
It's...
Fire.
I've sold my kidneys three times.
I have no idea what's keeping me alive.
Haha, okay.
How are you in this fine day?
Yeah, I didn't get nearly as much money...
Oh yeah, the flaming homer!
You mean the flaming moe, guys.
No, no, no, it's the flaming moe.
I went to the... one of the Universal Studios and got a flaming moe.
Like the... the cup for it?
Hey, I've got to pay protection to 11 separate criminal organizations.
Let's see, like, my love tester.
What am I?
Am I a... Oh, I'm a cat!
Oh, I'm a cold fish.
That's okay, guys.
This machine is busted.
Bye!
What did I win?
What does it taste like?
It was years ago.
I don't remember, but I still have the cup for it.
I actually don't remember, uh...
Um, what it tasted like.
I should say my game.
You're right, guys.
You're right, in case it crashes again.
Haha!
A pet.
How are you this fine day?
I just found out my genitals of cauliflower.
What?
That's very rare.
How does that even happen?
Greetings, loyal customer.
God help me, I love books on tape.
How are you this fine day?
Are you saying I'm ugly?
Cause I am.
Greetings, loyal customer.
Uh, I'm out of doves, so you gotta drink balsamic vinegar.
You know, they retcon...
They retconned Moe so much.
Oh yeah, I think the voice actor for Moe is one of the most highly paid voice actors on the show.
Because apparently he voices like a million other characters on The Simpsons.
Um, but like they retconned Moe so fucking much, it's actually crazy.
Cause one of the retcon was that the reason why he's so ugly is that he used to be a normal looking boy.
And then like he gone through a horrific, like, accident that made him ugly.
And then, but then there's like other retcons too.
I don't remember the other reasons.
I don't...
Um...
Uh...
Igna, thank you.
Welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Oh yeah, he's married to the, the dwarf girl now.
By the way, yeah, he has like so...
Wait, is he married?
I don't remember.
They retconned that too.
So like, he bumped into this like, uh, this girl who was a dwarf.
And like, um, and it was, it was a little person.
Wait, is that the correct term?
I forgot.
Little person, right?
Who was a little person?
Or is, sorry.
Like, she didn't suddenly grow taller.
Um...
I...
She, she still is.
She didn't just suddenly just stop being a little person.
And then they, she like, fell in love with like...
Oh look, I'm too, I'm American!
Yeehaw!
I'm American!
And so, the story is that...
He fell in love with a little person.
And, um, she like, disappeared.
And like, broke up with him.
It was all one episode, by the way.
And then later on, he like, found her again.
Cause they were like, I can't stop thinking about you.
And everything.
And then they were gonna get engaged and everything.
And then I think she like, ran out.
I don't know.
I don't remember how the episode ended.
But like, they got together and then she never appeared anymore.
Yeah, she returned.
She returned.
And then they got back together and were engaged.
And then like, I don't know what happened to her.
And then it just, they just sort of like, forgot about that storyline.
Like, I mean, Groundskeeper Willy also got married too.
But they didn't really do anything with the wife.
No, she didn't die.
She was, she faked her death.
But like, I remember she like, faked her death or some shit.
Yeah, they, they got engaged.
But they haven't done anything with her.
She like, disappeared at one point.
You're no stereotypical Italians.
Pleased to tell me the source of the evil cola.
We don't know nothing.
Except that the vans are controlled by mysterious strangers.
What?
Anyway, you shouldn't stick your nose in other people's business.
It could come back the whole...
Mo asked if little person was the correct term when we first met her too.
I liked them as a couple, so I was sad they broke up.
No, they're back together now.
Rodrigo.
Thank you to the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh no.
We're back together!
Yippee!
Wait, am I going the right way?
Oh, it's this way.
Wait.
Wait, can I just...
Guys, I have an idea.
Yippee!
I figured it out.
I was like, if this works for the house.
This shit... Wait, okay.
I have to do this again because my... Oh, no.
My car might explode before I get home, though.
My car was like, I figured it out.
No more crashing out for me.
Oh, no.
Give me a sec.
I need to... Oh, no.
Okay, I have 15 seconds to get to the hospital.
I don't know if I'll make it.
Guys, I may or may not have fucked around too much.
Oh, my God.
Are you serious?
Is there anywhere I could go?
Is there any... Please, are there any taverns I could go?
Oh, wait.
I did it.
Okay, I just drove around.
That's fine.
All right, here you go.
Yay!
Thank you.
Come here.
I should come in my pants for this.
Let Dougie take... Oh, Dr. Hibbard!
Oh, no.
Oh, yeah.
And then they gave him...
Oh.
What happened to the babies?
Diapers aren't covered by your insurance.
No!
You better hurry.
I heard the parents of the Shelbyville 9 are grabbing every diaper in town.
I will get the diapers, but there's no way I could fit them in my car.
Maybe Mr. Homer will have a large gas-guzzling American vehicle that I could use.
You'll need to purchase Homer's custom-built car.
Purchase it from the Homer's parking...
Homer in the hospital, park it for $500, call it from a phone booth.
No!
I spent all my money to be American!
The American dream!
Oh, no.
Here you go.
Truly the American dream!
Too real!
I spent all my money trying to be American!
How would I know I have to get $500 more?!
How?!
The American experience, alright.
It's time to farm money, guys.
It's time to farm money.
Have no...
Oh, yeah.
Sorry, I was saying thank you to the super chat.
What the fuck?
Monkey delivery.
Bye, monkeys.
Where's the monkey gonna go?
Why would they random monkeys?
Oh, God.
Hi, Dr. Nick.
Alright.
Maybe stop killing the monkeys or the people?
Question mark.
Alright.
Oh, nice.
There's more bees.
I hate that.
They're so hard.
Let me kick you!
It's not fair!
You have a force field!
There you go.
I have no fear.
We got stories for years.
Like, Marsh becomes a robot.
Maybe Moe gets a cell phone.
How about crazy wedding?
Have no fear.
We got stories for years!
Thank you for the super chat, Zara.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah.
A little bonus.
Dr. Hibbert...
Um, they added more, like, character development on Dr. Hibbert.
And, like, him and his wife have an absolutely terrible marriage.
And his wife is cheating on him.
So, like, that's, like...
And then, like, they always, like...
Almost, like, every episode or so...
Like, every two or three episodes or so...
They do, like, a little storyline where, like...
His wife hate...
Like, is, like, unsatisfied with his...
With their marriage.
Yeah.
It's, like, extra stuff.
Like...
And then they did, like...
They did an episode parody of...
Oh, what's that show about the island?
I didn't watch this show before.
But there's, like, this new show on...
I think it's on HBO.
About, like, an island resort where, like...
People go...
Like, rich people go there for vacation.
And the Simpsons did a parody of it.
I don't remember what show it was called.
No, no.
Like, Lotus!
Yes, they did a Lotus parody.
Yeah.
My giant gut is...
Is slowing me down.
And then Sideshow Bob got married for the seventh time.
And he got married to, like, some...
Some millionaire or some shit.
In that show.
I don't know if they're, like, still together.
Because she...
He, like, actually was, like, in love with her.
Alright, let's see.
Yeah, he got married.
He got married to a millionaire.
Wait, Sideshow Bob has kids?
Oh, my God.
I forgot about that.
I know.
Thanks.
There's so many things.
I forgot he had kids.
I know I should be using my car for this.
But, like, I'm trying to find money right now.
I spent all my cash on...
To be American.
Alright, let me...
Oh, my God.
There has to be more.
I'm gonna steal your car.
Let's see.
There has...
Oh, this song is so groovy.
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
That has to be...
That has to be money right there.
I see a coin path.
I see a path of coins.
I am, like...
I'm, like, a bunch of rats following some coins.
Following treasure right now.
Okay.
Buddy.
Oh, wait.
There's one over here.
Okay.
I need this car to come back.
It's time for parkour.
It's time for some funky Indian music.
Now, go here first.
Nice.
I knew it.
I knew you had something for me.
I knew you were holding out.
Okay.
Nice.
We're at 400.
We need 100 more.
It's just 500 coins, right?
God.
I can't believe...
Why?
Why did you guys make me become American?
At this time?
In 2025?
Why?
Why did I become American in 2025?
I saw...
I saw how much you gotta pay for merch now.
I'm scared.
I...
In this economy...
So real.
Okay.
My giant gut is...
Alright.
It's slowing me down.
Oh, no.
I heard that...
You know what's good now?
Okay, it's not great.
But I heard like...
Okay.
The bad thing.
I heard like...
One of my friends was like...
Really sad about...
The...
Extra money they have to pay.
But like...
They were like...
No!
Timu's not shipping to America anymore!
And I couldn't help but laugh at that.
I...
I felt bad for my friend.
But they got...
They were like...
They're like...
I can't...
No more Timu!
Yeah, apparently...
Apparently...
Uh...
Timu had to...
Stop...
Um...
Timu basically stopped shipping to America.
Like...
I can see my house from here!
No more Timu!
Um...
But I heard like...
Some places are...
Offering to hold your product...
Until like...
They don't have to pay as much.
So like...
At least some places are giving options.
You know?
You might have to wait like...
You know...
A year or so to get it.
But at least you have...
You get to still have it.
But I heard like...
That's what some places are offering.
Yeah, holding warehouse.
Yeah, yeah.
How would I shop like a...
How would I shop like...
My pavilion there now?
Oh yeah, my American hat.
Oh yeah, back here.
Oh, it like...
Circled me back here.
Nice.
Oh, there must be...
The plushies are delayed, Doki.
The plushies are delayed!
Hey!
No!
Oh my god.
I hate this fucking bee!
Okay.
Nice.
Alright.
I'm almost close to 500.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No!
I'm feeling sorry for you guys.
I really do.
You just did it once.
Oh.
Oh, I guess like...
Taking care.
I was gonna say...
I was gonna say a poo.
It was one time that she got pregnant.
Not eight times.
What do you mean stamina?
But then I realized...
Oh yeah, like...
Taking care of children does...
Does stress out a lot.
Oh!
Monorail!
All right, nice.
I wanna sing that for karaoke.
I wanna sing that for...
If I ever get into a concert, I don't know when I'll ever...
Um...
I think like...
I wish I was a better singer so I can have more opportunities to sing.
Like actual...
Like, you know, like...
Um...
Opportunity slash offers to sing.
Like, does it...
That's like the one thing I wish I was good at.
Which is singing.
So that I could do like...
Uh...
Chip post songs for concerts.
Because I would definitely...
I would definitely sing Monorail for a concert.
Like...
Like a...
A fucking idol concert.
I'd be like...
Who's that?
Monorail!
But stopping you.
You know...
Money.
Concerts are...
Also like...
Um...
That's the reason why people would go...
Use like...
Outside organizers for it.
Um...
Cause like...
Organizing concerts.
And like booking venues.
And getting rights to song.
It's a lot of...
Time.
Money.
And like...
Effort and stuff.
So I can't do that on my own.
Alright.
Nice.
We have $500.
Where is Homer?
I don't know where Homer is.
Hahaha.
Alright.
Have you been practicing singing?
No.
My throat has not been the greatest...
The last couple of months.
So I really haven't had it...
I don't know where Homer is.
Like I...
I...
There's no...
Why is there no...
Where is he?
Hahaha.
Where's the hospital?
I don't remember...
Oh, it's this way.
I remember now.
Don't worry.
See, I remember traffic.
That's the hospital, right?
No.
That's not the hospital.
Wait.
Where is...
Oh, that's the hospital.
There's Homer.
I see him.
Wait.
Where is Homer?
Wait, no.
That's the museum.
Where the fuck is the hospital?
Oh, there's the hospital, guys.
I figured it out.
There's the hospital.
Uh...
Sorry.
I went through like seven different loops of where the hospital was.
See, I told you.
I remember where it is.
Um, but...
My throat hasn't been the greatest, so I haven't had a chance to even practice singing at all in any way.
Um...
Because...
Oh, wait.
Isn't that Homer's brother?
Oh, my God.
What's wrong with the motto?
Like, they'll never see the inside of the car.
Mr. Homer, sir.
Do you have an oversized vehicle that I might be borrowing?
Borrowing?
No.
Selling to you at an insanely high price?
Yes.
Fine.
Whatever.
It's fine.
I'll just keep selling.
Oh, my God.
Is this car?
Oh, the car that bankrupted his brother's company.
The Homer.
How much did it take to build this?
I'm broke.
Oh, no.
I actually tabbed out.
That's not what I wanted to do.
Okay.
I need to save my game after this.
It is too much.
Hit the Shelby build van and collect the diapers before time runs out.
Okay.
Let me...
Oh, fuck.
I can't.
Okay.
It's fine.
All right.
Before I go...
Okay.
I should...
All right.
Where is it?
We got to hit the van and collect...
Oh, this better have good RAM material, Homer.
You did bankrupt your brother's company.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
How many kids are in there?
Oh, my God.
That's a lot of children.
Okay.
I need to hit it 10 more times.
That's fine.
Nice.
Nine.
Oh, yeah.
They were more popular than me because they had one more kid.
They were like, oh, my God.
Congratulations, Appu.
For having eight children.
And then right after, this bitch had nine.
I bet it was not even natural.
Like, my wife.
My wife.
Oh, yeah.
For those who don't know.
Like, it's very hard to naturally have eight children.
Usually, it's like...
Like, it's like...
What was it?
They do it, like...
Science-wise.
I don't even know what it's called.
Like, they have to artificially have that happen.
Yeah, it's not actually natural.
I mean, like...
How could that be natural?
Where is my other car?
Dude, where's my...
I swear to...
Oh, my God.
Please.
Please drop it.
Oh, my God.
You have to be kidding me.
Let me take that.
Oh, my God.
Thank God.
Okay.
I was going to freak out.
I was actually going to freak out.
I...
He was going to block me from getting it.
I was going to freak the fuck out.
I...
She actually blocked me.
I told you I didn't crash out.
I swear to God.
If she actually, like, blocked me from getting that fucking...
From getting the...
The diaper, it was over.
It was...
It was over.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
I want his car.
Usually, they give you extra cars if you do their missions.
Excuse me, nice Mr. Shopkeeper person.
Have you seen a hovering death machine?
No, nothing specifically of the hovering kind.
Oh, yeah.
I forgot to say.
This was to be my greatest invention since sideburns in a can.
They make you handsome and lovely.
What are you talking about?
I call it the hover car.
TM.
Don't try to steal the names.
The hover car.
I installed the onboard computer.
And it came alive and attacked my person.
For the love of all that's gliding, you gotta help me here.
Okay, what on earth can I do?
Knock the flesh rigging the thing off the road.
Before the authorities come and take me away again.
Prisons ain't kind to pencil neck geeks like myself.
They...
They stomp and they kick.
Oh, no.
Okay.
Find and disable the hover car before time runs out.
Alright, I'll...
I'll cancel this mission.
And then...
I'll...
Save game.
There you go.
Nice.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
Good.
Alright, I'm ready.
I'm ready, nerd.
Alright, we have find and disable this car.
I left this door.
Hoodlums put pornography in the bridal magazine.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
What?
Wait.
Okay, someone was like, you should...
Wait, it's invisible?
Oh my god.
What kind of car is that?
This is bad.
Guys, I think it's over.
I can't even make it over.
He's...
It's such a fast car.
Wait, is this gonna be my car?
Oh my god.
It's gonna be my car if I do it correctly.
I...
Oh my god.
This car...
Now that's a car.
Ba-bum-bum.
Ha-ha-ha.
Sorry.
Are you fucking...
Oh!
I can't.
We got...
This car will destroy itself before I destroy it.
Like, at this point.
At this point, this car will destroy itself before I can make it to it.
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba.
Oh, okay.
Um...
I think it's over, guys.
I don't know where I am.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha.
Where am I?
Where is this car?
Destroy yourself now.
The car.
Please.
Where is it?
Oh, no.
Maybe it'll destroy itself, guys.
I have hope.
We'll see the car suddenly.
Just go up.
Oh my... I think it's... Oh wait, it was... Oh, it's waiting for me.
Guys, do you see that?
It's been waiting for me.
Actually, the car was... The car was waiting for me this entire time.
I am having so much fun.
It's trying so hard to, like, help me.
I can't.
It was... How kind.
How kind of it.
Okay.
Oh my god, this is good.
Either you or I.
This is good.
No, why did I let him get out?
Oh my god.
Why?
I was so confident.
Oh my god, we did it!
Okay.
This is okay.
This is not okay, guys.
Because, like, my car is not doing so well.
And I started... Oh wait.
Wait, there's a wrench.
Woo!
Never punish, baby!
Oh wait, where is Professor Frank?
Oh, it's so far.
I forgot how far he is.
He might be really far, guys.
I'm scared and disorientated.
Me too.
Oh no.
Oh, there is, there is, there is.
Oh, thank god!
We just made it!
Give me that car!
Great work, my Hindu friend!
Not... Never punish, guys!
Never punished!
Look, if you need a ride, instant message my Cortex.
By which I mean, call me!
Oh my god, nice!
I got the hover car!
See, I told you!
I told you!
Everything, everything goes for Doki.
Alright, let's steal that car.
That was a cool car.
Wait, that's not the hover car!
Wait.
Alright, toughness.
Oh, but this acceleration is really fast.
Wait, how fast is the...
How fast is...
Oh my god, there's so many cars.
How fast is this car?
Wait, this car is better.
Wait, the car built for Homer is so much better than every...
How did it go out of business?
This car is so fast!
How did this car go out of business?
Look, and it has this.
Mean Windaloo Machine!
Ironically, it looks...
Too...
You're right.
It was too ahead of its...
I'd buy this car.
It was just too ahead of its time, guys.
Woo!
Oh, I went the wrong way.
What in the hell were you thinking?
Alright, $82,000 in...
Okay, but like...
But like...
This could be like a Ferrari, you know?
Alright, hello.
Hello, Christy.
Hello, famous American clown.
I wish to ask a favor.
Yeah, I mean, it's like...
It's this...
This time's Ferrari.
If someone was willing to buy...
The armored car, someone will buy this car.
I'm a drink, squeezy, punchy lowlife.
You need a professional scumbag.
Follow a cop until you find one.
You'll have better luck if you...
You know...
Yeah, if people buy the Cybertruck, people will buy this.
Alright.
This little...
Follow up for police to find the criminal.
You're into your criminal.
Okay.
I'm sorry, I love...
I just...
I love the horn.
I can't help.
I like the simple things in life, guys.
And that brings me joy.
It really does.
Um, excuse me, ma'am, I did hit a person.
Get it right.
Okay, how do you get this done in... uh, 19 seconds.
Guys, I don't think I'm gonna make it, guys.
I fucked up a little.
C, 17, 18... OH MY GOD, YOU WHY?!
LEADY DRIVE!
I got it.
All right.
Follow.
Jesus Christ, he's so fast.
The goddamn road rage.
Oh my god.
I'm following as much as I can.
Back down to the last donut.
All I'm seeing, it was not my fault.
She should have opened her eyes.
All right, get back here!
Get back here, Popo!
Oh!
Fuck!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Chief Wiggum!
I have your son!
Hindu coming through.
It's not that difficult to get him.
He's very easily persuadable.
Don't lose it!
I'm trying- You think I'm fucking trying to sabotage myself?
No, are you fucking kidding me?
Are you... Jesus Christ.
How can you be such a good driver?
She's incompetent.
Okay.
Alright, nice.
I was gonna say how the fuck... What is that driving?
Yes.
Wait, I wanna go into the... I'll go to the DMV.
Hello.
Hello, ladies.
How are you this fine day?
The doctor said I should be dead years ago.
Greetings, loyal customer.
I'm more likely to be hit by a meteorite than I am to have a baby.
Whoa, damn.
That's fucked.
Don't worry.
I got you, Mo Man.
That'll be $5.
Thank you.
Come again.
Alright.
Hello.
Head over your wallet, dude.
This is totally a mugging.
What?
What good luck?
A criminal?
Huh?
Surely a violent filthbag such as yourself could find out who is driving the black cola vans.
Well, I do have a connection at the DMV, but it will cost you.
Wait, how much?
You have to pick up the litter from a community service.
Oh, okay.
That's fine.
Now hand over your wallet.
Wait, what?
Yes, yes, whatever.
Yes, yes.
We'll keep doing the same thing over and over again.
Hopefully my store will not be robbed more than four times while I am driving.
Driving around today.
Alright.
Follow the garbage truck.
Wait.
That's not how that works.
What?
It's a really bad day.
Alright.
One.
Wait.
It's just five.
It can't be that.
Wait.
How?
Four minutes to do all?
Okay.
I know there's...
There's something wrong.
What do you mean?
Four minutes to collect five?
Five?
Oh, there...
That's...
Oh, I know there's something more.
That's suspicious right there.
There's more to this, isn't there?
There's more to this.
This mission doesn't seem right.
What do you mean?
I got one minute to collect 21 donuts and this one was like four minutes to collect five?
Wait.
Why did it stay at four?
Wait a minute.
This timer doesn't feel right.
Come on.
Drop another one.
Okay.
Collect our remaining garbage for snake?
Are you serious?
There's...
Oh my God.
Okay.
I get it now.
Oh my God.
It's...
I...
Oh my God.
Okay.
I get it.
It's parkour time.
Okay.
That's fucked up.
That's actually fucked up.
Okay.
Now I get it.
Just give me a minute to catch my breath.
Oh my...
No!
I should sleep now.
Oh my God.
The cameras!
The God damn...
Guys, it's over.
It's over.
Guys, it's already over.
It's already over, guys.
That was...
That's what sealed my fate.
That sealed my fate, guys.
Yo.
This is so fucked up.
You're slowing me down.
This is worse!
Where's...
Where's the rest?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Just give me a minute.
Where's the other ones?
Where...
Are you fucking...
Okay.
Oh my God.
Are you fucking...
I could've just ran through.
I could've...
I can't...
I should sleep more.
I did it!
My guardian shot.
Come to papa, random object.
Okay, now I know though.
I'm flying!
I...
Okay.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
My giant god is...
21.
22.
23.
And then...
24.
25!
Oh my God!
Drive to the DMV!
Ah!
Okay.
Where's my...
Okay, there we go.
I will pay you a million dollars in the next life.
I promise.
I'm driving.
It's okay.
Everything is fine.
I remember where the DMV is.
Oh no.
No!
Ah!
It's so far!
Why is it so far?
No!
Ah!
Why is it so far?
Put you put photography in the Bridal magazines.
There was a shortcut.
Oh fuck!
There was a shortcut!
And I didn't... no... no...
I'm falling in the parkour area.
That was... are you serious?
Oh my god, and then he does a u-turn.
And then he fucking does a u-turn, this fucker.
This actual fucker.
Oh my god, I can't believe it.
He fucked me up.
This mission, this mission is bullshit.
This mission is actually bullshit.
Okay, it's so far from the DMV too!
Okay, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
I know he goes this way.
I just gotta wait.
All right, all right, I'm locked in.
All right, and then...
Get out, get out of the car, get out of the car, it's parkour time!
Get out of the car!
Oh my god, it's parkour time, this stupid fucking...
Oh my god, I'm stuck!
Okay.
Come on.
No!
Slowing me down.
I can't.
It's already over.
Why do you put parkour?
Why?
Oh my god, it's already over.
I didn't crash out, guys.
I kept playing, guys.
There was no crash out.
There was no crash out in Ba Sing Se.
I didn't crash out.
I kept playing.
I kept playing everyone.
There was no crash out.
Okay.
I need you.
Get over me.
Give me your car.
Okay.
My... No!
No!
No, you cannot be fucking with me right now.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my God!
Wait, where's the... Oh!
I forgot about the alley!
Holy!
Just give me a minute to catch my breath.
Oh!
It's over.
There's only... I forgot about... It's already over.
I... It took me 28 seconds to even get on that car.
It took... It's already over.
It's already over, guys.
There's no way.
I'm making it there in 20 seconds.
It's... There's a car in front of me that's... Oh my God!
Is this the shortcut right here?
Is this the shortcut, guys?
Okay.
We're not getting this car anymore.
Yippie!
Okay.
We got... I'm getting a different car.
This ain't it.
This is not the right car for me.
Oh.
Whatever.
Okay.
Doesn't matter.
This car is so hard to drive.
I knew it.
This ain't it, chief.
I hate how it does, like, a detorture and then comes back.
Like, make up your mind!
Okay, I figured out the parkour, guys.
I figured it out.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
Everything is so fine.
I... Oh, my God.
Oh, my God.
Okay, it's fine.
Everything is fine.
Everything is so fine.
I hate this car.
I absolutely hate this car, guys.
Alright.
It's parkour time.
It's park.
Here we go.
Back to the roots.
Okay.
Okay, I made the first...
The first hurdle.
The first hurdle is done.
Just give me a minute to catch my breath.
Okay.
Alright.
Ramp time.
Boom.
Okay.
And then we gotta steal a car.
I should sleep more.
Alright.
Oh my god.
It's broken already.
What do you mean it's already?
Okay.
I'm so focused right now, guys.
You don't understand.
I hate this level so much.
Oh my god.
I didn't realize that was all.
Okay.
I'm running.
I'm locked in.
Okay.
We need to grab.
Oh my god.
Which one was Homer?
Give me a ride.
I will pay you a million dollars in the next life.
I promise.
Alright.
This is it.
Okay.
Good time.
Lock in.
Lock the fuck in.
I just gotta go.
Oh fuck.
Gotta go straight.
I gotta go straight for the shortcut.
This better be a fucking shortcut.
I swear to god, guys.
Guys.
Oh, Shiva smiles on such behavior.
Guys, I don't think this is a shortcut anymore.
Guys.
Oh, wait.
What are you trying to prove with this crazy driving?
Oh, no.
Move it, Cracker.
What the...
Oh my god.
It was...
It was a shortcut.
Oh my god.
You didn't lie.
Chat was right.
Oh.
Chat was actually right.
Thank you.
Thank you, my violent associate.
Oh my god.
We did it.
Got to enter the DMV.
I can't believe it.
Chat was actually right.
I got the folder.
Chat was always...
I didn't get one guide.
Oh my god.
Alright, here's the folder.
Yeah.
One thing, but I never expected you to lie.
Dude, relax, okay?
I've got the info you need.
I just need help with a little more community service.
Huh?
I'm totally evil.
I should know better than to trust that demented chuckle.
But okay.
Okay, it should be fine.
Help Snape with his community server.
Destroy the armor car and avoid cheap Wiggum.
Alright, this will be fine.
No, it's okay, guys.
What could go wrong?
By not saving.
Alright, guys.
It's alright, guys.
I love playing.
With fire.
Okay.
It's the risk.
What's...
It's so...
You know, the risk is half the fun.
You guys...
The risk is half the fun, guys.
Don't worry.
Oh my god.
How far is the Googleplex?
Okay.
Oh wait, oh wait.
Oh shit, sorry.
I didn't even realize I'm getting...
I didn't even realize I was getting chased.
I was like, hello, chief Wiggum.
How are you doing?
I was just...
Chilling with the cops, you know?
I was literally being like, hey, how's it going, chief?
What are you doing in this fine day?
Okay.
Now we drive to the Googleplex.
Nice.
Oh, I should get the wrench real quick, too.
Before I go to the Googleplex.
This town is going to pay for this.
Hasta la vista, suckers.
Alright, nice.
Okay, if I'm going to be ramming stuff, I have to go to the...
Get that wrench first.
I make this look easy.
Oh my god.
It's armored!
I have a convertible!
Like...
What in the hell were you thinking?
My car is a convertible!
What do I do against that?
Oh my god!
I'm trying my best!
Bro!
At least it has no time.
I think I have to do this before my fucking car crashes.
Yes!
What the hell was Snake thinking?
This is...
Oh my god!
My car is going to explode, guys.
Guys, I need to find a wrench.
Give me a sec.
This car...
No then...
Snake doesn't think...
Clearly!
Why did you bring a convertible on this mission?
I need to find a wrench!
I'm just following, guys.
Give me a sec.
My car will explode if I touch him one more time.
You'd be no time, man.
Is there...
Where are the wrenches?
Oh, there's the wrench.
There it is.
Okay.
Alright.
Got the wrench.
Okay.
Alright.
At least...
Things will be okay now.
Okay.
I'm just slowly...
Ramming it slowly into...
Into the wall.
There we go.
As long as he keeps hitting himself, we're fine.
Alright.
As long as my car is okay, we're fine too.
Okay.
There we go.
Let me...
I have the wall on my side.
Oh my god.
That's fine.
Alright.
Nice, nice, nice.
Yippee!
The wall!
He's just gonna hit the wall.
He just needs to hit the wall one time.
Oh, wait.
He wanted to turn.
Okay.
I didn't think he was gonna turn.
Go to the wall.
Come on.
Be a good truck and go to the wall!
Nice!
Hit yourself again!
Hit yourself!
There we go!
This beat to the community.
Shut up and take us back to the fight out.
Alright.
I mean, um...
Charity.
Alright, nice.
Guys, look at that.
We did a good deed.
We're going to get charity now.
Look at that, guys.
We're a good guy.
We're gonna get rewarded for our charity work.
Can I write this as...
Can this be a tax write-off?
Yippee!
I love charity!
Uh...
I never played this while I wanted to go into GTA 3 and say...
Hey, you have time now!
You have one more year until the next GTA comes out.
So, I might as well play this game.
Hahaha!
Morgan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Is that too soon?
Yippee!
Hahaha!
Too soon, guys?
Guys, I'm gonna make it.
Nevermind.
Alright.
Let's go this way.
I feel like Chief Wiggum's gonna chase me, isn't he?
This feels like a chase angle.
I fucking knew.
Wait!
Moe Savern is right behind me!
Wait a minute!
Moe!
You know what that means!
Hahaha!
What?!
No!
Ah!
No way!
I'm sad.
I can't.
You mean the strat didn't work?
No!
I thought I was so smart.
The devs knew.
They actually do.
They got me.
I couldn't.
I couldn't get past the devs this time.
You will be reincarnated.
They baited me.
I can't believe it.
I got outplayed.
I actually got outplayed by the devs.
What a thought.
Oh my god.
I had to do the armor card again.
I thought I was doing so well.
I thought I was being so smart.
I was like, hee hee.
They planned it.
They knew.
They fucking knew.
Ew.
Now it was the word.
But sh- I was like, wait.
Bo's tavern is right here.
Oh my god.
I know what to do.
I played myself.
I have to do the stupid armor card shit again.
All right.
It's fine.
I know where to go.
Okay.
It's not that bad.
There's less traffic right now.
It's not rush hour anymore in the Simpsons universe.
Ow.
Wow.
All right.
Now to do this again.
God damn it!
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
I know where to go.
I know where to go guys.
It's fine.
Oh shit.
Okay, I know where to go guys.
It's fine.
Okay.
I know how to lose him.
It worked before it shall work again.
How is this?
Nice.
Okay.
Okay, it's fine.
Quick go to Bo's.
It'll work this time.
All right.
It's fine.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
I just gotta fix my car.
Before we do the armor car shit again.
Let me find a wrench real quick.
Oh, there's a wrench.
It's okay.
I have a wrench right here.
See?
Nothing wrong is gonna happen to me.
All right.
Back to the armor car.
Oh no.
Okay.
It's okay.
That's okay.
It's fine.
As long as I don't run over anybody else or hit any other car, we're okay.
And just grind to the wall.
Grind to the wall.
Dude, you better not have scratched my car.
No.
Grind...
No!
Fuck!
Oh my...
God, I hate this car.
What are we gonna do now.
That's right, what are you gonna do now?
Nothing.
No, I can't!
Why isn't it hitting the closer to the wall?
Oh my god.
The scratching ASMR.
I'm so sad.
Wait, wait, wait.
Here we go.
Here we go, I did it.
This needs to be against that wall.
There we go.
Lots of damage.
Oh my god.
The stupid fucking truck.
There we go.
Yes, hit that wall.
No, I was supposed to hit the wall.
Yes.
Yes, hit Mayor Quimby.
Nice.
Okay.
Now hit that.
Good.
Plan, plan.
Now hit that.
Please, please hit that pillar.
Hit that pillar.
Yes.
Okay, look.
See, look at that plan.
It hit the pillar.
That's all I wanted.
Hit the ambulance.
There's nobody in there.
And if there is, she's already dead.
Okay, I need to hit it.
Squeeze it to the wall again.
My...
Oh fuck, he was gonna turn anyway.
God damn it.
Here we go.
Grinding it against the wall.
The damage will build up on itself.
Slow and steady, guys.
Slow and steady.
Win some race.
It's gonna eventually hit.
It's a long game.
No!
Okay, I need to fix my own car first.
I gotta find a wrench.
I can't grind it against the wall anymore.
And we gotta make sure we don't lose the truck.
It's working, but like, my car's not okay.
My car is absolutely not okay right now.
So I need to find a wrench before I do anything else.
Don't worry, I can follow you till the end of time, car.
Until I get a wrench.
Oh, there it is.
Wait, where is it?
Wait, where did it go?
Oh, there he is.
There he is.
You thought you could lose me?
You could never lose me.
That's right.
I'm always right behind you.
Right behind you.
I'm always here.
Don't worry.
Y'all never escape me.
Oh.
I still have that wall.
There you go.
Still have the wall.
That's right.
Oh, where the fuck?
That car wanted in on the action.
There we go.
Jesus Christ.
All right.
You did it.
Me and that wall, we have history.
Oh, no.
Okay, I need to get rid of cheap Wiggums.
This time.
All right.
Time to drive back home.
Let's go.
All right, Chief Wiggum should be nearby now.
Guys, no more going to Moe's this time, guys.
I learned my lesson.
I'm not going back to Moe's.
Despite how tempted I am, we do not go back to Moe's.
Wait, we make sure we do not go back to Moe's, guys.
God damn it, how do I lose him?
Do I go this way?
Oh, I did it.
Wait, what?
How did I...
How did I lose him?
Where did he go?
Oh, nice.
I don't know how I did it.
We're not allowed that.
Not on Fox.
Back then.
We're registered to the museum.
The museum?
What?
Each level of this adventure is more exciting than the last...
Thank you all for coming.
Yeah.
I'll see you in the hall.
Talked apart.
All right, guys.
Before I do the next one, how many more mini missions do I have for a pool?
Before I do the next one, I just want to make sure.
Look at that car.
Which one?
In this one.
Oh, gas.
I don't know.
Oh, yeah.
I should save.
I'll save game.
Last one?
Okay, it's the last one.
All right.
All right, I'll do this last one.
I have time.
Oh, Mr. Bart.
I have discovered that the evil cola is being made in the Springfield Museum.
But that closes in five minutes.
And my car is out of gas.
Just fill it up at the Quickie Mart.
At those prices?
No way.
Fine, we'll take my car.
Oh, nice.
Drive.
Oh, wait.
Bart's back to normal.
That's what?
Must admit, the smell of fresh air is much more...
20...
They said five minutes!
Wait, Bart has...
Bart, how did you get this car?
Bart...
What is this?
Right, the last time I saw it, it was a rocket car.
Where did you get this car, mister?
Also, they lied.
They said I had five minutes.
This is not five minutes.
Oh, no.
Destroy the corridor's car?
It's another...
Oh, man.
It's another fucking...
I did not realize it was another destroy mission.
If I knew...
This might have not been the last...
Oh, my God.
Where am I?
I got put it against the wall like I did before.
Oh, my God.
The Quimby thing was definitely...
Why do I have to use Bart's fucking car?
Oh, my God.
I'm trying to...
I don't like this.
Okay.
Nice.
Keep crashing to itself.
Okay.
Come on.
Oh, I made him faster.
No!
That undercard sabotaged me.
Did you see...
Did you see his license plates?
Oh, my God.
I can't barely turn.
No.
He needs one good hit.
Please.
Just hit yourself.
Hey.
Please.
Please hit him.
Just hit him.
I don't care if you rush me.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
That's fine.
I'll take that.
I'll take it.
I'll take it, guys.
He destroyed himself.
Oh, my God.
Where's the museum?
I don't know where the museum is.
Oh, my God.
There was a shortcut right here, and I didn't know.
Oh, my God!
I don't know where the museum is!
Oh, we made it!
I never thought I'd say this, but I'm actually excited to be going to a museum.
I don't know the map!
I'm so confused!
Shiva H.
Vishnu!
The cola is dripping from that meteor!
What?
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh, my God!
He's alive!
Smart girl!
Huh?
Oh!
Oh, that's how it works?
Life always finds a way.
What did it?
We destroyed a priceless archeological artifact!
I mean, it's a Springfield, it could be fake!
Now, let's find out who's behind all this strange cola business.
I know it's cliche, but...
My caramba!
Kodos!
Look at these space ratings for foolish Earthlings!
What happened, Kang?
Foolish Earthlings used to be the number one reality show in the galaxy!
Guys, I can't say kill up a girl, guys!
It's trading...
Ha ha ha!
Our show is down in all key demos!
But our show concept was so perfect!
We film these idiotic bipeds with hidden cameras, and beam it into every television in the galaxy!
Come on, you knockers!
These aliens have been secretly filming an intergalactic reality show in Springfield!
I knew there was a simple explanation.
Oh, so that's what the bees were!
I would introduce an evil cola into the water supply!
People will go mad!
I like it!
Then we distribute laser guns at the Squidport tourist area!
The cola maddened humans will go berserk!
I like it!
Ha ha ha!
Destroying themselves and their town!
Delivering...
I like it!
Ratings for foolish Earthlings!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Oh, for the ratings!
You've got to prevent the aliens from putting laser guns in the hands of cola-drunk townspeople!
Why?
That sounds hilarious!
I know!
It sounds fun!
I'll watch it!
You're a bad little boy!
Ha ha ha ha!
Shriva, bitch, Vishnu!
My humilation knows no bounds!
Alright, we're gonna call it here!
Oh my god, we actually...
You know, I...
All I'm gonna say is I improved in smashing cars!
Guys!
I got better at smashy-smashy!
You have to admit that!
That is character development right there!
Ha ha ha ha!
I...
I improved in smashy-smashy!
Yes, I did!
Alright!
I'm gonna call it here, guys!
That's fun!
I had a lot of fun!
I don't know!
The Simpsons in the run was a lot...
Despite how much rage it induces in me, I do have a lot of fun with it!
Um...
I improved a lot!
There's been character development in my smashy-smashy!
I got better at car destruction!
Yippee!
That's always a good thing!
Um...
I'm gonna go visit Dad now after the stream!
But...
Thank you all for the well wishes today!
I really, really appreciate it, guys!
Um...
Thank you, everybody, for coming today!
And for watching me!
As always, everybody...
Um...
Sorry for, like, a quick abrupt ending!
Like, you know, I couldn't talk to you guys longer!
But that's why I did talk more in the beginning of the stream!
Um...
But, yes!
As always, everybody...
Stay hydrated!
Pause check!
Get up and move around!
To get that blood flowing!
And if you step from me...
Head to bed!
Cause...
You deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time, everybody!
Bye, guys!
Bye!